[MUSIC PLAYING]
SETH: Welcome to
Talks at Google.
So today, we have a special
guest with us, Zaria Forman.
My wife grew up with her, so
I've known her for a while.
But I always remember a few
years ago a photo of her
in front of-- working on one
of her large-scale drawings
showed up on the
front page of Reddit
and created quite a buzz.
I think seeing the
artist in front
of this giant work of
art, a big iceberg,
was just really
visually striking.
And I feel like the momentum
from that is still going,
and she's fresh off
another sold-out show.
Congratulations.
So yeah.
Here is Zaria Forman to
talk about her new work,
and welcome.
[APPLAUSE]
ZARIA FORMAN: Thank you.
Thank you for that intro.
Yes, my mic is on.
OK.
I'm really honored and
excited to be here today.
Thank you, Phil,
for inviting me.
Where are you?
There you are.
And Seth.
And thank you all for coming.
This is just, yeah, I'm
really thankful to be here.
So I consider it
my life's mission
to convey the urgency of
climate change through my work.
And to that end, I've
traveled to the polar regions
to capture this unfolding
story of ice melts
and also to the equator to
document the rising seas that
are a result of the ice melts.
My drawings explore
these moments
of transition and
turbulence, but also
tranquility in the landscape,
allowing viewers like you
to connect emotionally with
places that you might never
have the chance
to actually visit.
And I choose to convey
the beauty of these very
remote regions as opposed to
the devastation in the hopes
that it will inspire
people to want to help
protect and preserve them.
To start out, I want to play
you something that I recorded
on the Antarctic Peninsula.
It's a sound piece that just
premiered in my solo show
in Seattle, Washington.
And I recorded it
in 2015, the winter
on the Antarctic Peninsula.
And it's a really
subtle sound, so I
invite you to close
your eyes or just
relax in whatever way
feels comfortable for you.
[DRIPPING]
So this sound is fondly
referred to as ice crispies,
as you might be able
to see if you squint.
I've also heard it called bergy
seltzer and ice sizzle, which
I've adopted as my DJ name.
But what it is is the sound of
ancient air meeting new air.
It's the sound of
glacial ice melting
and these tiny
little air bubbles
that are trapped inside
of it breaking free.
And also, there's
a whirring sound
which you may have
heard in the background,
and those are gentoo penguins.
So each of these tiny
bubbles popping open
contains a treasure trove of
information for scientists.
And I recently met
with one of them
named John Higgins, who is
a professor of geosciences
at Princeton University.
And Higgins and his
colleagues can basically
obtain the age of the ice
by studying these bubbles.
And what they do is use very
careful chemical measurements
to reconstruct both the local
temperature and the ancient
atmosphere-- so basically, how
much carbon dioxide and methane
were there--
from the time when the ice
bubbles were locked inside
of the ice sheet.
So the records
from these archives
show, basically, how our
climate has changed in the past
and what that might
portend for our future.
So it's important information
that we need to know.
And these ice bubbles
are hundreds of thousands
of years old.
In this picture, I'm
holding a piece of ice
that's a million
years old actually,
and he told me it was
a million years old
after he handed it to me.
And I was just like, oh my god,
don't know melt in my hands.
But actually, the results from
John's latest trip suggest he
collected ice that's 2 to
2 1/2 million years old.
And it's no news
to any of us that
these massive ancient
cooling systems that we
have at our poles that can
take millions of years to grow
are rapidly melting
and that that could
have devastating consequences.
And we know it actually
already is having
devastating consequences.
There's all kinds
of horrible news
out there about climate change.
There is the fact
that the past three
years have been the
hottest on record,
or that the polar bear
population in the Arctic
is in rapid decline.
And now we're faced with an
administration that is choosing
to ignore these problems.
I mean, even just these last
two weeks felt like apocalyptic
to me.
I mean, I'm sure you've
heard about the earthquakes
and the hurricanes.
And I was just in
Seattle last week,
and there was literally
ash falling from the sky
from the forest
fires in Washington.
And so yeah, bad
news, but I want
to switch gears and tell
you about an interview
that I read recently where Al
Gore is talking about how we're
doing in this battle against
climate change 10 years
after "An Inconvenient
Truth," his first documentary.
And what he said actually
surprised me, which
is why I want to talk about it.
He said even though we're
behind on the scoreboard
when it comes to climate change,
that the momentum has shifted
and that we're starting to win.
And I think he's right.
I think he's onto something
because we do actually
have a lot to celebrate.
First, of course,
there's the Paris Accord,
which, even though the
US has pulled out of,
I actually think that's
a good thing because what
it did was galvanize the
whole rest of the world,
including most major
US corporations,
to reaffirm their
commitment to it.
Obama managed to permanently
ban offshore drilling
in most of the Arctic
Ocean and important parts
of the Atlantic,
which is a huge win.
Iceland and Costa Rica run
on 100% renewable energy.
Solar power in Chile is selling
for half the price of coal.
Even just in the
beginning of this year,
the World Economic Forum let
us know that solar and wind is
either the same
price or even cheaper
than fossil fuels in
at least 30 countries.
Nationwide, there's
a long backlog order
for electric cars.
There are real
solutions that exist,
and we're already starting
to see benefits of them.
And I think it's a
pretty effective tactic
to emphasize the positive.
A bombardment of terrifying
news which I just threw at you
is paralyzing, but focusing
on the positive I think
is empowering.
So that's what I try
to do with my work--
to celebrate what is still
here and to give you,
give viewers, the
sense that it is still
possible to do
something to protect
this earth that sustains us.
So with that mission
in mind, my process
always begins by
traveling to these places
at the forefront
of climate change.
And while I'm on site, I take
thousands of photographs.
And then, back in
the studio, I work
from both my memory
of the experience
as well as the
photographs to create
very large-scale compositions,
sometimes 12-feet
wide like the one in this video.
Occasionally, I'll reinvent
the water or the sky
or maybe change the
shape of the ice
just a little bit to create
a balanced composition,
but I'd say 90% of the time
I'm depicting the exact scene
that I witnessed
because I want to stay
true to the landscape that
actually existed at that point
in time, which-- just something
to take note of-- is often very
different by the
time I've finished
the drawing several
months later.
So I begin with a really
simple pencil sketch
just so I have a few
major lines to follow,
maybe the outline of the
iceberg and the horizon line.
And then I typically jump in
pretty quickly with the color,
layering pigments
onto the paper.
And I smudge everything
with my fingers and palms.
I tend to break the pastel
into these sharp shards.
Oh, I work with soft pastel.
I should have told
you that first.
It's basically like
charcoal but colors.
So I'll break it into
these little sharp shards
that I can use to
render the finer
details on top of the
base layer of pigment
that I've already put down.
And typical paper
used for soft pastel
has a lot of tooth, meaning
a very textured surface
so that it's able to absorb
as much pigment as possible.
I actually prefer to work on a
much smoother paper than what
most pastel artists would
want because it allows
me to get those finer
details without the texture
of the paper getting in the way.
The challenge with
this, though, is
that there isn't a lot of
room for error or reworking
since the paper can't
absorb so much pigment.
But I honestly
enjoy this challenge
because I get so lost
in the tiny details
that I would just
never know when
to stop if the
pigment and the paper
didn't provide those kinds
of limitations for me.
So I am aware that
most people can't
access many of these really
remote places that I draw.
And so, in a lot of ways,
the environmental issues
there might seem remote and
disconnected from their lives.
So that's one
reason why I choose
to work on such a large scale--
to recreate the wonder
of witnessing an iceberg
or a glacier up close.
And I rely on other
specialists like scientists
to make rational,
data-driven arguments
for why we must take action
to protect our ecosystems.
But through my work, I'm
trying to make an appeal
on a more elemental level.
According to behavioral
psychologists,
much of our decision-making
comes from our emotions.
And I think art has
a special ability
to tap into those emotions.
And it's not just
something I think.
It's like scientifically
proven that it does.
So when I make
these drawings, I'm
trying to create
immense images that
are just overflowing with
detail that draw you in
and transport you.
An author named Elaine Scarry--
she's a Harvard English
professor-- wrote a book called
"On Beauty and Being Just."
And in it, she talks about how--
she suggests, I
should say-- that when
we witness something
really beautiful,
be it a wave or a face
or a poem or a glacier,
that it causes in us what she
calls a radical decentering.
And she says, quote, "When
we see a beautiful thing,
our own importance
is diminished.
It is not that we cease to stand
at the center of the world,
for we never stood there.
It is that we
cease to stand even
at the center of our own world.
We willingly cede the
ground to the thing
that stands before us."
That is the exact
experience that I
hope to evoke through my work.
So this last school year,
I gave a series of lectures
at Harvard University.
And in my preparation
for my talks,
I was scrolling through their
environmental center's website
and looking at their
Climate Week from 2015.
There were a bunch
of videos from it.
And there was one that was
particularly compelling to me
that it featured
a father and son
duo, Bob Keohane
on the right, who's
the professor of International
Affairs at Princeton
University, and his son
Nat on the left, who
works on climate issues at the
Environmental Defense Fund.
And one thing that stood out
to me that they both emphasized
was this notion of momentum--
the same momentum
that I think Al Gore
was talking about-- that for
there to be effective climate
policies, we need people and
parties from different arenas
to work together
in an ongoing way.
So that's how I
see my work fitting
into the bigger picture.
I just want to be part
of that conversation,
helping to generate momentum
and unity of purpose
across boundaries of
discipline and geography
and political affiliation.
So I guess by sharing
these moments of stillness,
paradoxically I'm hoping
to help generate momentum.
In their talk, I
also found it really
touching to see how
one Keohane had passed
the torch onto the other because
I think it taps into something
essential about climate change
work, which is its purview is
intergenerational.
The work is about
passing the torch
and thinking ahead
several generations.
And I think, perhaps,
I might be particularly
attuned to that dynamic
because of the debt
that I owe to my mother,
Rena Bass Forman.
She was a fine art
landscape photographer.
And in the last 10
years of her life,
her work focused on the Arctic,
and she passed that torch
on to me.
My mother's love
of photography just
propelled her to
the most remote,
far-flung places on the planet
that she could possibly find.
And my family and I were
fortunate to join and support
her on those adventures
from riding camels
through Northern Africa to
mushing near the North Pole.
She always said that she was
a polar bear in a past life,
and I never doubted
that to be true.
She could just
stay out for hours
on end with frozen eyelashes
and a giant smile on her face,
and the rest of my family was
like, I'm hungry and cold.
But she just loved it.
So in August of 2010
and '11, she and I
were planning an arctic
expedition together
to Greenland called
"Chasing the Light."
It was to be the second-ever
arctic expedition
with a mission of
creating art inspired
by the dramatic geography there.
And the first was lead in
1869 by an American painter
named William Bradford.
And what was unique
about that trip
was that its main purpose
was art as opposed
to science or
exploration, which is
what was happening in that day.
So my mom thought,
well, wouldn't it
be fascinating to mirror
Bradford's journey
and travel up the northwest
coast of Greenland
to seek inspiration
from the same landscape
nearly 150 years
after Bradford had?
So she and I were in
the very early stages
of planning this
trip when she was
diagnosed with brain cancer.
And the cancer
pretty quickly took
over her body and her
mind, and she passed away
six months later.
But during those six
months, during those months
of her illness, her
dedication to the expedition
never wavered.
And so it felt
like a duty to me,
like I felt responsible
to carry out
this mission in her honor,
which I did in August of 2012,
leading a group of
artists and scholars
on a four-week expedition.
My mother's affection
for the landscape
really echoed throughout my
own experience in Greenland,
and I felt both
the power but also
the fragility of the landscape.
I mean, the sheer size of
the icebergs is humbling.
And the ice fields, they
vibrate with movement
and sound in a way
that I never expected.
That's what prompted me
to bring my recording
equipment on my
more recent trips
so I could bring
that back to you.
And it's also why I decided to
expand the scale of my work--
to give viewers that same sense
of awe that I had experienced.
The melting glaciers
in Greenland
are one of the largest
contributing factors
to rising sea levels,
which have already
begun to drown some of our
world's lowest-lying islands.
One year after my
trip to Greenland,
I decided to fly to
the Maldives, which
is the lowest and flattest
country in the entire world.
And while I was
there, I collected
images and inspiration
for a new body of work--
drawings of waves
lapping along the coast
of a nation, a whole nation
that could be entirely
underwater within this century.
While I was there
with my collaborators,
we shared the concept
of our project
with children at the
Iskandhar Elementary School
at the nation's
capital called Male.
And we basically
just invited them
to document their
landscape as it transforms
throughout their lifetime.
And hopefully that can
help to bring awareness
to their island, which is
actually still very much
needed, surprisingly enough,
and also just help them
kind of inwardly,
emotionally process what
is happening around them.
Last winter, I had
the honor of serving
as the artist-in-residence
aboard the National Geographic
Explorer in Antarctica.
I have traveled to
many stunning places,
but Antarctica is just
in a category of its own.
The ice just like
radiated sapphire blue,
as you can see in this
video, and it just
took my breath away.
It's what inspired
a whole body of work
that I just completed that
I worked on for the last 18
months.
And I'll just show you a time
lapse of one of those pieces.
It's called "Whale Bay."
It was inspired by a place
called Whale Bay that's
on the Antarctic Peninsula.
And the bay is situated
near a glacier that's
calving icebergs into the sea
as all glaciers eventually do.
But the wind and water
currents carry the icebergs
directly into the bay because
of where it's situated.
And since the bay
is kind of shallow,
the icebergs will scrape
against the sea floor
and become what's called the
grounded, which basically means
they remain there until
they've melted completely,
which is a process that can
take years if the icebergs are
large enough like this one.
And bays that enclose
icebergs like these
are called iceberg
graveyards, which to me just
seems like a metaphor
for the bigger picture.
I had the opportunity
to ride around
this bay for two hours
in a small zodiac boat.
This is a video I took there.
A zodiac is a little
rubberized like 12-foot boat.
And you'll actually
start to see the iceberg
on the right-hand
side come into view.
That's the iceberg
from the drawing
that you just saw me making.
It's from a slightly
different angle.
So if you don't recognize
it, it's not my fault.
But yeah, we got to ride around
for two hours just weaving
around the most
intricately-sculpted,
glowing blue icebergs
I have ever seen.
I mean, the longer
that they stay there,
the more the water and the wind
sculpts these blocks of ice
into just otherworldly shapes.
And I shot like
thousands of photographs.
At times, I had to just
force my camera into my lap
so I could simply be present and
take in the overwhelming beauty
of it all.
And so I hope that my
drawings, as much as you
can see on these screens, can
offer you a similar experience.
So this past October,
I had the opportunity
to see Antarctica from a
whole different perspective.
NASA invited me to join them
on Operation Ice Bridge, which
is the largest airborne
survey of Earth's polar ice.
We flew 12 hours
every single day
that the weather permitted
on the DC-8, which
has the most comprehensive
suite of instruments ever flown
on long-range flights,
including laser, radar,
an infrared sensor, digital
photography, and something
called a gravimeter that
houses Einstein's brain.
It measures gravity somehow.
I don't know.
It was an incredible experience.
It was humbling to
witness the science team
and aircrew's dedication
to their seriously
hard and grueling work.
And the data collected
provides crucial information
about ice loss--
basically, what the
melting of ice sheets
could mean for sea level rise
and what the melting of sea ice
could mean for the entire
global climate system.
This year, the
Antarctic sea ice loss
has been particularly swift.
We even had to make some
last-minute modifications
to one of our flight plans to
account for the significantly
diminished sea ice.
When NASA measured its
extent for this time of year,
it was at the lowest
level ever recorded
in reliable satellite history,
which dates all the way back
to 1979.
And since that year,
since 1979, the planet
has been shedding massive
amounts of sea ice annually
that equal an area larger
than the state of Maryland.
The scale of this loss is
difficult to comprehend.
And similarly, my
sense of perspective
was completely warped
as we flew over the ice.
And just to give you
an example of that,
this is a photo from one of our
flights over a glacier called
Land Glacier, and it covers
the equivalent of 54 football
fields in that photo.
It's just, I mean,
it's crazy to me.
It looks like a little crumble
of ice on the sidewalk.
But that little blue crack
is probably 100 feet wide.
So this past April,
I was actually
able to join NASA's Ice
Bridge team again on some
of their arctic
missions, and we flew
over ice sheets, sea
ice, and glaciers
in arctic Canada and Greenland.
And it was just totally
thrilling to fly--
once again, only 1,500
feet above the ice.
The instruments need
to be 1,500 feet,
so it's actually
pretty low for a plane,
and you really get
to see the detail.
And it was just
so exciting for me
to compare the ice to
its southern counterpart
but also just reconnect with the
science team and the aircrew,
and kind of chilling to
learn of some of their more
recent discoveries such
as a giant crack that
is forming in the
Petermann Glacier, which
could in the future--
this is a picture of the crack.
So it could, if it
splits off the shelf,
mean a new ice island--
basically, a giant iceberg--
that's twice the
size of Manhattan.
Findings from this close to
a decade now long project
are numerous and some of
them mind-blowing to me.
For instance, they
found a canyon larger
than the Grand Canyon under
Greenland's ice sheet.
Just like, we had no
idea that it was there.
It was just hiding
under the ice sheet,
bigger than the Grand Canyon.
But the most significant
data from the project
have shown that the entire West
Antarctic Ice Sheet has likely
entered an unstable
state and might now
be in irreversible decline.
And although the timing of
that retreat is unknown,
it's still a powerful
reminder that we've
entered a new era with
significant changes
on the horizon.
Our president has already
begun to defund NASA's climate
research.
And the lead scientist at Ice
Bridge, named Nathan Kurtz,
recently emailed the
team and I to say, quote,
"In these uncertain times,
it is vitally important
that we reach the hearts
and minds of people
around the world to communicate
the importance of the work
that we are doing."
So I just want to
thank you for having
this opportunity to share not
only their really important
mission, but also my own work.
And I hope that you'll
spread it as much as you can.
And it's just an
honor to speak to such
an influential audience.
So when I was in Greenland
back in 2012, that first trip,
I scattered my mother's
ashes amidst the melting ice.
And now, she remains a
part of the landscape
that she loved so much even
as it, too, passes and takes
on new forms.
Among the many gifts
that my mom gave
me was the ability to focus on
the positive rather than dwell
in the negative.
And honestly, that
lesson has rarely
felt more necessary than now.
And yes, it's become far more
challenging to stay positive,
since January especially,
but I'm doing my best.
And I encourage
others to do the same.
And former Secretary
General Ban Ki-moon
said at the most recent climate
change conference in Morocco
that action on climate change
has become unstoppable,
and he's absolutely right, and
those are the words that I just
keep reminding myself of.
On our family travels, every
time that we came across
a really spectacular view,
my mom would do this thing--
and I apologize in advance
because I'm going have to get
loud--
she would go, oh my god!
And that was a taste because
I sound exactly like her.
But it was special.
She saved it for only
the best of the best.
And so it would
happen once, usually,
maybe twice if we were lucky,
on a four-to-six-week trip,
on each four-to-six-week trip.
And so, every single time we
approached a really beautiful
view, my dad and my
sister and I would
glance at her wondering if it
passed the "oh my god" test.
I try to uphold her reverence,
her legacy of drawing attention
to the beauty of
these remote places,
and I try to embody her
resolve and intrepidness
I am so utterly grateful for
the time that I had with her
and also for the
time that we all
have to appreciate
what is around us
and to take action
to protect it.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
So we were going to
do a Q&A, but I also
have a video piece that is
also premiering currently
in my solo show in Seattle.
And it's kind of subtle.
I recorded it on the Antarctic
Peninsula, the same place
where I did that drawing that
I showed you the time lapse of.
And so I'm going to let
it play in the background
while you guys ask me questions.
And here it is.
There we go.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about technology
and how it's been used
to amplify your message.
Seth talked about Reddit.
I know with the campaign,
that you raised money
for the trip to Greenland
and then now with YouTube.
Can you talk a little more
about how technology is helping
with the momentum as you say?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
A few years ago,
as Seth mentioned,
my work kind of went
viral on the internet.
And I still to this day don't
really know how it happened,
but I'm grateful for it.
And the momentum
that that started
hasn't really ever stopped.
I mean, I think I had
done enough work in the 10
years previous to
kind of back that up.
It was like a ripe
time for it to happen.
But I'm certainly
really grateful that it
did because it just helped.
I mean, it's so easy to
spread these kinds of messages
really far across the
planet and across the globe.
And so I really used especially
Instagram, social media
as a tool to share the
missions I went on with NASA
and also just the
work that I'm doing.
Did I answer
everything you asked?
OK.
Cool.
Oh.
Also, I should say that like
Instagram itself has really
become I think like the
best way, for artists
especially, to promote
their work because it's
such a visual platform.
So yeah, I mean, I've sold
a lot of work on Instagram,
which that never would
have happened 10 years ago.
It's just interesting
how things have changed.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ZARIA FORMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: First
of all, thank you
for your very beautiful work and
your positive energy on a topic
that I think is pretty
tough and scary.
My main question is, with your
work, what is your main goal?
Is to document and
share, or to inspire,
or are you urging people to
take action, just people like us
or organizations or politics?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
Good question.
My main purpose is to
share, to give viewers
a place, a time, and a moment
to feel like they're there,
like they're transported to
these places that are otherwise
like so not connected
to our everyday lives,
and to ideally stir up
an emotional connection.
Because, like I said, when you
have an emotional connection
with something, when
you love something,
you want to protect it.
And so that's the idea is that
I spur that emotional connection
and then they go on
you to take action.
I'll offer things.
I'll give websites.
I donate a percent of
my sales to 350.org,
but I have a whole
page on my website
that's like, here's how you can
cut down your carbon footprint.
But I feel like there is a
lot of that out there, which
is awesome, and that's
not like my main purpose
even though, yeah,
of course I want
to direct people
in the right way
so that they can take action.
But I'm trying to
translate the data.
The data is out.
Like, we know the science.
But somehow, still,
almost half of our planet
doesn't believe it or just
doesn't want to see it.
And so clearly, that hard
science isn't enough.
So I'm trying to just offer the
best way that I can communicate
the importance of that
and the scientific stuff
that might not be as
easy to digest and have
an emotional connection with.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: That's very bright.
ZARIA FORMAN: I
know, on me, too.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
Thank you as well.
It's really inspiring not only
to see some of the context
behind what you're doing,
but also how you do it.
So I like that you touched
on both pieces of actually
how you work with the pastels
and what the reasoning behind
is.
And to touch on your last
point of kind of accessibility
of the message--
so I think the
data is out there,
the science is out there.
That's very difficult for
a lot of us to understand
and many more to understand.
And so I think sometimes
these decisions
are emotionally
driven rather than
driven by the data and
the science backing it up.
And I'm just curious.
I think the way that you're
going about it, to kind of try
to create an emotional reaction,
is probably making this
a more accessible message
than maybe NASA's message
or something to a
much bigger audience.
And I was wondering
if you could just
touch upon that, if
you've seen that you're
able to make that
message more accessible,
or maybe any lesson learned
you have from making
that a more accessible message?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
Absolutely.
And that's exactly what I'm
trying to do, so thank you.
I'm glad that you
think it's doing that.
A big part of that, too, is
the realistic way that I draw.
The way that I'm drawing all
the details, it's not abstract.
It's accessible
not only to people
who aren't interested in
science, but also people
outside the art world's bubble.
A lot of people who
have purchased my work
and who want to are
first-time art buyers.
They just want to be able to
see that image in their home.
I think there's a lot of art out
there that's not so accessible.
And this is just like,
you look at an image
and you know what
it's about, and you
can have a connection
to it because it's
part of our planet.
We all live here.
So yeah, in every
facet I try to make
it as accessible as possible.
And I do think that it's
succeeding in that way,
hopefully.
Of course, people only tell
me that they love my work.
They don't tell me
if they hate it.
But yeah, I have had a bunch
of people come up to me
and just say like, thank
you, like I had no idea,
or now I've changed
these actions in my life
because of what you said.
So that's the most gratifying
things that I can hear.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
ZARIA FORMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: You said you
take thousands of images
and you have access to videos.
So how do you choose which
images to actually draw?
ZARIA FORMAN: Oh, good question.
It's probably the hardest
part of my job, I think.
It takes hours and hours of just
scrolling through and editing.
At this point, I have
lifetimes over enough material
to continue making
work for many lives.
And I still want to
go back and continue
to be inspired by
these places selfishly.
It's hard to describe because
I think a lot of the time it's
just like a feeling.
I'll be scrolling
through images,
and then all of a
sudden something
will really stand out to me.
And so that's often
how it happens.
It's just like the
composition just feels right.
It's not about math or like art
theory about the horizon line
has to be one third
up from the bottom.
It's just like, oh, there's
something about that just like
has the right feeling.
And it can be hard
because I have
an endless amount
of photos and video,
but then I can also
crop them endlessly
and zoom in endlessly.
So yeah, it's definitely
the hardest part.
I spend a lot of time
scrolling through
and staring at the
computer screen and lots
of icy pictures.
AUDIENCE: I'm
wondering what comes
next after the icebergs
and the disappearing
islands in the Maldives?
Will you sort of stay on theme
with environmental changes
or maybe do something
else entirely?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I can't tell
the future, but I
do think that I could continue
with ice and sea level rise
for the rest of my life.
Until it stops inspiring me,
I'm going to continue with it.
And I don't see that
end anywhere in sight
just because there's so
much more that I still
have to learn about rendering
its different textures
and surfaces.
And that's what excites
me, just to learn
something new with every piece.
And so immediately what's
next is, from all these trips
I did with NASA, I gathered
a bunch of aerial footage
and photography, and I'll
be making a series that's
from that perspective.
So some of those photos you saw,
it will kind of look like that.
It's a little bit
more abstract looking.
It's real.
It won't look abstract.
But I'm curious to see
how that will unfold,
and it's exciting for me.
But that will be my next exhibit
in New York in October of 2018.
But yeah, like I
said, there's just so
many textures and surfaces
and ways that it's melting.
I mean, water has so
many different forms,
and I just don't see
an end in sight where
it will stop inspiring me.
And I also think climate
change is arguably the largest
crisis we face as
a global community,
and I don't see that
going away anytime soon.
And so it's important
to me to connect
whatever I'm doing to something
meaningful for the rest
of the world.
So I see myself
doing that forever.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
Thank you.
Anyone else?
AUDIENCE: So when
you are drawing,
are you making a
conscious effort
to stop yourself from
exploring and transforming
the image, the photograph,
or how you do trade off
between maintaining the
accuracy of the photograph
and going full on into
an abstract thing?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
I mean, I want to portray
the exact landscape
that I witness because I'm
trying to stay true to it.
I just want to be
honest about what I saw
and try to give people
that same experience.
So the only time I ever
elaborate or change it,
it's a very small
percent of the time,
but it's really
just like if I have
this beautiful image that
I feel like is really more
powerful than anything
else that I've been looking
through but there is like,
oh, the corner of the iceberg
goes off the corner of the
image and I want it to stay
contained inside with a little
bit of background behind it.
It's just that, just
to artistically create
a balanced composition so
that it gives you as much
of a wonderful, comfortable,
loving feeling as possible.
AUDIENCE: Could
you talk a bit more
about the
collaboration with NASA
in that how did that come
about for you as an artist?
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
So one day, I got an email--
[LAUGHTER]
--from NASA's-- he
was a navigator.
He's basically
their lead navigator
for airborne
terrestrial exploration,
not extraterrestrial--
so basically flying,
exploring earth in flight.
And he just reached out.
He came from a
family of artists.
He didn't say that
in his first email,
but he was just like,
hey, I found your work.
I saw your TED Talk on
Apple TV in my preparations
and research for my
next trip to Antarctica.
And I thought you
should come with us.
And so here's my phone number.
Call me.
I remember very
clearly this day.
I had a friend coworking with
me in my studio, and I was like,
what?
I read him the email.
He's like, oh my god.
And I was like, I think I'm
going to call them immediately,
but I kind of think
this is a hoax.
And I called him and he
had this like radio voice,
and I was like,
this can't be real.
And after several conversations
and several months and lots
of planning, I
still didn't think
it was real on the plane flying
down to Punta Arenas, Chile,
where I was going
to meet the team.
And it really wasn't until
like that evening when
I walked into the
first science meeting
that they had every night
at 6:00 PM where I was like,
oh, I'm not being kidnapped.
[? There ?] [? on a ?]
[? plane, ?] a bunch of NASA
scientists here.
So yeah, I'm so grateful
for this opportunity
to collaborate with such
an incredible project.
And I was so intimidated,
too, at first.
I'm an artist.
I'm a weird quirky artist.
To go meet a bunch
of NASA scientists
was like really scary.
But they were so warm and
welcoming, and a bunch of them
had even known my
work before and were
really excited to meet me.
And way more than I
expected, they really
understood the value in
communicating their message
in a different way that they
haven't been able to do.
So I think all of them are
really grateful that I was
there and doing what I'm doing.
So it's been a really
incredible experience.
I'm actually going
there tonight.
Right after I leave here,
I'm getting onto a train,
and I'm going to be speaking
at NASA's Goddard tomorrow, so
excited to see all of them.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thank you.
There's definitely an
element of scale in your work
and I think also in how you are
really amplifying the message
and know this change.
I think you had an image up
there that was some cracks.
Like, that crack right there
could be 100 feet across.
I'm curious about how
you think about scale.
Like, did your work
start at a smaller scale?
Yeah, just more on that.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
I guess my professional work
began my last year in college,
and I was working
pretty big actually.
I made a couple of 6-by-8-foot
pieces for my senior show.
And I was drawing
really big skies--
storms, hurricanes from
weather photography.
So scale has always
been important to me.
But especially after I got
back from that first trip
to Antarctica in
the winter of 2015,
I was just like, how
can I do this landscape
justice without going as hugely
massive as possible, as much
as I can afford and
can do in my studio?
Because it's just so epic.
And it's like, you can use
all these grandiose words,
and it's like nothing
really describes it.
And that's why I am trying
to draw them because I don't
know how to put it into words.
So yeah, I feel like the
scale is really important
to make you feel like you're
standing in front of a glacier.
You need that scale.
It's so important.
And so I do work--
I make smaller pieces as
kind of more like studies,
but also just because
they are so much easier
to transport and sell.
But the larger ones are
really where my heart is.
I love to spend a whole
year working on one piece,
making it as large
as I possibly can.
So if you know anyone that wants
to pay for that, let me know.
[LAUGHTER]
One thing that people
tend to comment on
so I'll just say something about
it is a lot of the drawings
or most of them, there isn't
really a sense of scale
because I'm not putting
a little penguin
in there or little boat.
Part of me wishes that
there were something
I could put in there
that didn't seem cheesy,
like a penguin, that would
offer that sense of scale.
But, on the flip side, I think
it's kind of nice sometimes
because there are
drawings that I showed you
in this presentation
where an iceberg was maybe
as big as the drawing itself.
But when people ask me, how
big is that because it looks
like a mountain range to me?
I'm like, ooh, that's great.
It was this big.
And I actually like when they
think it's larger than life.
But I love especially
drawing at like a 1:1 ratio
as much as possible,
meaning the scale of the ice
was actually as big
as I'm drawing it,
because it just allows
me to really get
into all the nitty
gritty details
and just show you, show
viewers, exactly what the ice
texture looks like up close.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So first,
I think Google
should pay for that
gigantic drawing somehow.
ZARIA FORMAN: We'll email after.
AUDIENCE: So I really liked how
you shared the sound with us.
And it seems like
it's definitely
an attribute that will help
people get more immersed.
So I'm curious if you're
collaborating also
with people that can
create VR experiences
or interactive experiences
and sort of like scale
it in a different way.
You know the topic
and everything,
but you can probably share it
in different mediums as well.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
It is definitely a direction
that I see myself going in.
This exhibit that's up
right now is the first one.
That sound piece I played
you is my first sound piece.
The video piece I was
playing during the Q&A
is my first video.
And the exhibit in
Seattle right now,
I was really trying to create
that immersive experience
like you mentioned
because it just
allows you to feel like
you're there that much more.
And VR is almost, at this
point, the ultimate of that.
And so, yes, I would really
love to venture into that arena.
And I've been just starting
conversations with people
and thinking about
projects in the works,
but nothing is planned yet.
But yeah, definitely a
direction I want to go in.
I feel like everyone
here asked a question.
[LAUGHTER]
[APPLAUSE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I'll ask one
closing question really fast,
and I feel a little bad
asking after you've explained
why the scale is so important.
But can we purchase
prints anywhere and where?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
ZARIA FORMAN: No,
that's a great--
AUDIENCE: OK.
ZARIA FORMAN: Yeah.
Thank you.
So ArtStar.com sells my
prints, used to be exclusively.
Now, we also have a new
print that just came out
of that first slide--
I don't know if they
want to pull it up there,
but the one that I
first showed you of me,
I'm small on the corner
drawing it, and it's one big--
oh, the time lapse drawing--
that one is a new
print now that's
offered through Winston
Wachter in Seattle.
So you just have to
call the gallery.
And we're launching
a new print soon,
and there will be new
drawings available
as I start making
this next series.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]